hello you don't even know what the real
thoughts is dear
as usual we go I see this one you
probably won't think that is that bad
and this is why I've always wanted to
talk about for a while it's too bad man
forever let's talk about us movie didn't
we like talk about them we'll leave
knowing there is ok I'm about you I have
a ton I can talk about with this movie I
don't know why this is ok we talked
about this movie okay
ok fair enough I I feel like this one
there is a good movie trying to get out
of a math film and at its worst I just
think it's math I don't think it's not
it's not god-awful okay here's the thumb
let's think if let's say Benin I am
Robin never came out well let's say
Schumacher films didn't happen I went
from Batman Returns to did Batman Begins
if Batman Forever was to come out now
the rebooting Batman redoing everything
it would be the most hated Batman movie
ever made like if it came out right now
and there was no Batman or Robin and I
find that interesting but the same way
that one came out man it bent it forever
came out right now like they said ok
we're stopping with the DC Universe
we're guests do Batman over and this is
how we're gonna do it ok that's a vision
that would be the most every film is a
product of its time like only could have
been released and only could be what it
is because it came out right after bad
white turns but at the same time I know
what justice I need a king of all Batman
movie see it but the same time I know
what you're saying where there are
elements were like especially watching
it again I actually completely forgot
how good-looking the movie is it's not
Batman but it's gorgeous I like I like
what they're trying to do with the story
it's not done well but I like some of
the themes that bring up and what they
were trying to do it's just it's kind of
in this goofball corny universe yeah
well and the making of this film sounds
really interesting too I mean how's it
in a review like I mark it seems like
the sweetest guy I mean he's nothing
again she was I think he's made a few
good films but we may love falling down
he loved them and I love falling down he
knows how to shoot a film it falling
down is a film that would work
way better that movie was decades ahead
of its time
no no it works better because it is the
angry white guy movie it was and like at
the end of it you're just like oh shit
maybe like this guy's actually just
fucking crazy like yeah I think Yuri's
to see how people would react to those
released now I'd be really curious to
but anyway again anyway it so I don't he
just is always thrown in the wrong
project he fraud doesn't belong start
off its like the Maverick like with Lost
Boys and stuff like that then somewhere
he becomes another one that's decent and
then he sort of became the you know just
kind of do what the studio wants and if
you want to make it look nice that's
great but just do kind of what we want
he became the director that always he
played along with the studio which I get
you know and Ozzy face with his
personality cuz he seems like such a
nice guy you know he made that though
the studio made the same exact mistake
they did with Burton which is oh well
that movie was a success here's a blank
check do whatever you want that's how we
got Batman and Robin yeah because after
Batman Returns uh he was saying that a
lot of people did not want to make the
movie - okay we'll throw some money at
cuz it's Batman but everyone like it was
hard getting funding for it because
everyone just remembered Batman Returns
and they was scaring away kids and so he
really tried to play him okay know this
is a kid-friendly version and even he
kind of admitted like he wasn't entirely
sure what kind of movie he was making
and with Batman and Robin I think he
actually likes that one better cuz like
he know if he said I knew what I was
doing I was doing a giant funny goofy
toy commercial and just having a ball
with it you know like the Adam West and
overall if you were to ask me which is
the best well if you ask me which is the
best Batman movie for kids I would say
mask of the phantasm but if we're
discounting that and we have to go with
the original for I gotta go Batman
Forever
yeah well it's Batman BAM in the from
like a little bit Returns is for four
kids i I saw when I was 13 and I loved
it and I there are other kids who saw it
and came out of it fine but I mean it's
definitely like if you're just one of
those like worried parents
50 things like it's that movie just as
ugly but sexual innuendo and get aminos
in station biting nose yeah a very
awkward death scene involving penguin is
too pure I'll and but if you look at
bamm-bamm forever I'm like as a movie
aimed squarely at an under 10 crowd like
dad that is the best one where it's just
like okay it's just a dolt enough that
an adult can get through it not saying
you have to love everything in it like
to face I like it but if there's stuff
like him acknowledging the death of his
parents and you know under 10 feel adult
watching it like oh like it's me and
like everybody I know who loves
everybody it's they're always like 11
and under like when when it was released
and they're like that's right when I saw
when I saw this movie I think we said
this fucking bad okay I had a super uber
man crush on Jim Carrey because this
dude is doing everything I always want
to do is like I can't want to be an
actor as a kid and just seems you've
carried to this stuff it's like oh my
god you can do this a you could be a
huge star you can just act like an
insane little kid as an adult it's
amazing and just the fact that like cuz
he was still like really rising but then
like putting him in a Batman movie to me
that was just cementing him like okay
you are officially a star when that
happens when you're in a Batman movie so
like you literally could show me Batman
and Robin and weird thing about him in
the movie is he's not the worst thing in
the movie no Jones ooh like apparently
went up to carries as I don't approve
your buffoonery was he like trying to
derail Carrie by L I think I don't know
what it was but letting like his hands
down the worst thing in the film that
was also one of the most funniest things
of them cuz it's he totally yeah like
it's were teenagers terrible Batman
Robin but he's having such a ball and
he's just enjoying it so much that you
kind of laugh with him
yeah his I'm pretty sure his acting
coach was a chimp yeah better monkeys
just doing pure monkey um hurry
god bless the Riddler is the obvious
performances in the film The Riddler is
the worst
it's his nygma in either form the creepy
beginning form or the trying to be the
Bruce Wayne clone form is way better
than the Riddler you know and even but
here's the thing with that you can tell
like there's two nygma's when he's like
the long-haired crazy scientist you know
it's like half of it's like okay be like
a guy who really feels betrayed here is
like this guy who let's be honest he's
in love with I mean he is legit in love
with him and he just like totally
betrayed you and this changes your life
I mean like there's that and then
there's pee funny Jim Carrey
when he's be fine Jim Carrey I don't
think he's funny and I think he's really
annoying know when whenever he's in the
Riddler costume no God but even as early
nigma when he's like you know I'm
sucking up your IQ Cathy you don't tell
your like Serpico not like that bullshit
how do I put it is really like that's
the river into the green eyed guy it's
like yeah yeah but I feel like that's
the Riddler so he's not in the costume
yet but I feel like okay that's that's
the Riddler I'm talking about like just
when he's proposing this - yeah yeah
anybody who works on the convention
circuit has run into me here's the thing
I used to think this was over-the-top
I used to think his performance without
too goofy and everything but now it's
like no I've met these people anyone
that's gone in fan forums for anything -
Rick and Morty fan but I love this show
I got the shirt obviously but like
there's a lot Rick and Morty fans as
well as any fan base where it's just
like they've seen that Edward nygma
before it was like I'm gonna have to say
no I can't fund your Holocaust Muppet
movie gotta go
no no ly
to where it should be I think you
pointed out you said boys that like an
entitled fan when he says I need an
answer now I think I deserve it
yeah like that like I've seen that
multiple times that's happened to yes
and please do not get us wrong like we
love the majority of our fans like
there's so much love and we're talking
about fans meet like five yeah everybody
five percent of everybody I run into is
awesome but there's always that just
that the tiny me yeah and you just every
family think majority oh like Rick and
Morty fans as much as that whole
whatever nuggets I think was crazy it's
like but I know tons of people that love
that show and are like you know Thomas
right and and really the majority I
think that that weird minority a lot of
the began basis I want to develop over
the years I feel lucky I feel like ours
is pretty pretty yeah but but we know
these crazies - yeah yeah like every fan
base has that metal bat one scene yeah I
was like this is a different scene now
that's why I like these B+ let's be on
this porno pass what isn't amazing with
your friends and family that's even who
doesn't know it
yeah and I like his his version of him
trying to basically clone himself as
Bruce Wayne in the suit and everything
right down to the ball yeah I know it
was kind of stanley ipkiss it was little
truman show it was definitely he was
more restrained but I love the little
over-the-top moments where you know he's
just like dancing with chase meridian
and give him Bruce look like hey oh what
a gift because it's it's over-the-top
but I'm like okay it's funny I was
enjoying again kind of very much tie
into that he has a crush out of it you
know yeah even he's like he's he just
wants to dance with his woman and his
eyes are on him the whole oh yeah he's
got this hand moving
like what the very end he was gonna drop
her off a cliff yeah
you should care about her it's about
Bruce this was this was all about taking
out Bruce's two loves dick only the
Riddler's yeah I feel like okay so half
we're in Batman Rob and I felt everybody
thought they were making an Adam West
movie this one I felt half of them
thought they were making a legit Batman
movie the other half thought they're
Carrie Carrie to his credit I swear to
God thinks he's in the legit Batman yeah
Tommy Lee Jones see he's in Adam West
Nicole Kidman thinks he she's in EM West
I think who is some Cristal Val thinks
he's a real Batman movie I think Val
Kilmer thinks he's in a real Batman the
bail jumper goes back and forth I think
when he's Bruce Wayne he's like I'm in
legit bad memory then when he's Batman
like oh yeah
you know old trams are like yeah of
course Adam West would say that it's
tough because from what we're told Bruce
Wayne is supposed to be in the comics in
this and add I honestly feel Val
Kilmer's is the closest Bruce Wayne I've
seen cuz like I'm like okay what you're
talking I know because I can see this
guy as a playboy I love Michael Keaton's
Bruce Wayne I do not see him as a
playboy I just don't they throw him in
with Vicki Vale and Selena but I was
like I don't see that George Clooney
obviously we can see as a playboy but I
am I couldn't I couldn't take him
seriously I'm like kill me looks like
the playboy who's definitely hiding
something
yeah yeah George Clooney did not look
like he's the first Batman I've seen who
is reserved as Bruce Wayne which is
different and interesting and what kind
of make sense I really like it I'm not I
think this was oh he's good but I really
like the idea behind his Bruce Wayne and
the interpretation he was going with
even if it does come off as bland that
doesn't always work that yeah I mean
that I really like that his Batman
yeah I mean if that is the product he's
a very boring Bruce Wayne but it's like
you could argue he's almost like if you
were Batman like good I feel like yeah
if a person was Batman they would kind
of exhale better filmer would act
he's the Bruce Wayne that I feel is
probably what would be the most
realistic Bruce Wayne for somebody's
doing that I had problems with Christian
Bale because I was like I don't know if
Bruce Wayne would fake it out that like
it's like a mass or things are like I'm
just I'm just crazy I'm just I'm just
gonna pretend to be a drunk I don't
think you would do that and Affleck as
Batman we never see him in a greenhouse
yeah so I don't know what he's like he's
probably cement the one party with wit
yeah we're talking to Clark Kent who we
know or Wonder Woman like is so it's
like I'm gonna talk play BAM out get
talk super secret stuff I'm gonna we
never see what he's like even that's the
one thing I took out of this movie that
I really liked and why chase meridian
bugs the fuck out of me because i'm like
you could have had some really good
serious conversations here
what a great idea that he's dating a
psychotic and in so just one note i want
to get in Batman's pants and play with
this Batarang like yeah I just I hate it
I walk in and see what's underneath the
utility belt like all these bad puns
yeah and what's point you got someone
like Chris O'Donnell who is way too
goddamn old he was 25 he's like I want
to you with social services and the dzf
just like what you're like 25 you know
what but but - it's not - well no - is
credit a lot of things around the Robin
character including the performance and
everything is well done I think it's one
of the few things where I'm like yeah
kind of from beginning to end this is
pretty good I think of all people I
think it was our I'll go ahead a grave I
know he's like my problems with the
movie is it should look like Robin can
kick Batman's ass yeah I was like really
I think Chris O'Donnell should be bad I
think yeah I think he was saying that
with Batman or Robin but looking at this
one they're both kind of standing there
like he's got like his muscle cherdon
Val Kilmer's shirtless I'm like they
look about evenly match yeah least I'd
still bet the crystal dalgu kick is that
you know he's like oh come on you could
I was like dude you could knock this guy
you could knock Val Kilmer out easily
come on but then of course like when he
becomes Robin I'll give credit I think
that is the only Robin costume I see
that I'm like that's a cool costume dude
like they bucket me they're like that's
Robin that like I feel like about having
to go full Nightwing or something where
it's like yeah well we retard super guy
like yeah this is a good chance I like
to but but if like if you want to do a
classic Robin outfit like I'm like oh
yeah like that adds a managed dignified
am really cool and like you should
totally tell who it is
it still but but I thought it was a
really cool Robin costume we talked
about how we didn't we were joking we
didn't want to give it credit you were
not ahead of your time Batman frame yeah
I honestly yeah I think the box
commentary yeah wow there's the Internet
there's a hacking there's data stealing
there's I'm like this is like feeding me
sexual fantasies White Lies I mean
that's in my head they will go Viktor is
inevitable yeah I mean we're really just
like man yeah like this you know and I
I'm I'm super addicted to this oculus
rift is virtual reality thing and it's
just one of the things where it's like I
haven't done any of these chat room
where you can like go and socially chat
and stuff like that but I'm thinking
like yeah I'm even with steam and
everything like you're kind of handing
over all this information just the
Internet in general and it's like and
then next thing you know tokidoki
literature club it's not it's not one of
those things where it's like yeah you
can point to yet this is a direct
commentary to blank this company or this
organization it did it but it's like
this is kind of going on and I'm not
like a conspiracy theory thing but it's
like one of those things where it's like
the yet you can easily see the only the
only thing it's so antiquated about it
is that it's like TV related like that's
where the 90s part kicks it's the next
TV that's what it was yeah but I mean
Aldi and they're kind of bringing you
into these it sells to 90s and even even
the way it looks like some Nickelodeon
oh yeah yeah like it just there's
something about that that it's so 90s it
was like other than that though I'm like
it's pretty ahead of its time
yeah you should even even the line you
know they say the box turns people into
zombies nameless shrugs that's what they
say when TV was invented it's kind of
like yeah like we do can see this way of
progression and it's like people are
exploiting it I mean they're doing it
more secretly than like so Riddler but I
mean it it is being exploited and not
not probably to a grand scale that we
think yet at least math I know of but
it's like yeah it's like of course this
stuff is gonna kind of happen if people
are going to abuse it so yeah I thought
that was actually watching it again
we're just like oh my god is this like
kind of yeah that's the weird thing
about this home is I feel like it's both
it's both insanely dated now like
hilariously dated and yet also strangely
ahead of its time I'm like wow you could
play a couple of these ideas and scg in
this movie is awful the models are
pretty fucking cool
yeah like muscle work it's like oh my
god like models remember this one it was
really their little kind of fake but it
was really very GI is like occasionally
nearly food fight cause I'm like that
scene where you goes up to like the
Wayne like HQ with the waterfall and
everything that first opening shot I we
just looked into it was like wow I'm
like this is like ps2 shit right here
you know I was watching
I feel really Kevin Smith there's one of
those people I haven't gotten into his
movies for a while actually I love tusks
you talk about the commentary he does
commentaries for the back I did the
Batman Returns when I was laughing my
assets like yes let's open our new
Batman movie with infanticide I wonder
what the parents had a problem but like
i Kevin Smith this one those people and
I think he figured this out too like
whatever you say about create evil
creatively whatever like I can listen to
him talk forever like he is just fat
like he is so into geek culture and
comic books and stuff like that but like
the bigger ideas of them where I'm like
I'm fascinated by this dude and he's
funny and everything he didn't want for
Batman forever and all he was talking
about which it never
dawned on me but it's a really good
point he says look Chris hold on was
fine
the Robin you know the supplied is fine
and everything but I mean like really
look at this this was like a kid like a
13 year old or something like that and
yeah like parents and stuff would go
nuts that you're putting this kid danger
stuff I mean you're the kid watching
this you're 11 or 10 or whatever and
you're watching a kid along with Batman
like you know when he teams up with him
when he's saving him at the end just
imagine you're a kid watching this and
Batman saves little kid rather than
everything just wouldn't just be huge
like change the movie and everything
really close they Phantom Menace
territory I mean with young Anakin and
it's just like but you would have had to
have cast that film so perfectly that
yes the team that us-ally I was it was
this film 95
something like so I would have been 60
94 yeah I would have been 16 you would
have been like 14 anyway so but as a 16
year old I don't know if I would have
wanted to sit there and go oh great now
I gotta watch snow but kid no you only
think you're free Terminator 2 or
something like that Eddie furlong yeah
you get like that or you but that but
here's the problem though then you're
not making it see this is the problem
though that's not what the studio wanted
yeah this is where Kevin Smith is like
it's an interesting theory if you did it
right but he's dreaming there's no way
the studio would be like oh yeah let's
get a really broken kid like John Connor
from Terminator 2 swear and left and
right and Batman like strains about is
like that's gonna happen
you wouldn't dark territory of the law
you didn't like that and it also wasn't
you know Batman Forever yeah you had a
serious Gotham City in Assam where
everything was more serious sure like if
you wanted to do it like you know in the
nolan universe or even i would go like
the burton universe sure why not
but it did but not in this universe it
would have gone completely like star
wars territory like yeah i feel like the
only one I could think of is in the
animated series they made trays out
while the Robins for a younger Robin
animated series a series
yeah you know that that's one of the
things that were again I was just like
oh he's a little kid now but I'm like
good job I really like this kid no I did
she the first time I was a trainee it's
like a legit boy you know this seriously
but when it didn't talk down the kids it
didn't talk down to the adults or the
teenagers like us who are watching the
show so that was never gonna happen to
man no we're lucky and that's why I kind
of like this movie despite all its was
we're lucky it's as adult as it is
that's we saw we we saw what happened
with Batman and Robin so I look at this
I'm like I appreciate the good movie
trying to come out I don't hate this
film I just it's it's certainly it's the
third best of the original four yeah I
mean they go kind of in the corner I've
but I like returns more but that's more
of a guilty pleasure yeah but but I
still think the two Burton ones are
better and then there's this and then
Batman and Robin is if you dig like a
grave halfway to China it's one of those
where it's like it gets worse and worse
every time I see it but it's like gets a
little better know sometimes elements of
a get better that I can appreciate I
didn't appreciate visually how good it
was I didn't appreciate chase meridian
has gotten worse idiot to face having
not seen it since we did the RiffTrax
thing I was surprised at how much worse
she got just in the past
well ago yeah something like seven eight
seven or eight years ago I'm surprised
the past seven or eight years how much
it's hit me how really awful shit like
watching him like my god you are just
one note like what's your character poor
like that's em like in world's worst
psychiatrist yeah it was like she never
even jumps out of it's like uh-uh
so on a bang you like it's like Jesus
Christ lady yeah no and and then I I
think of something like I think they're
saying way of light to phase I think
Brian was saying this like when they
were building up the movie they were
saying well in the comic he goes back
before between you know good and evil
here he goes back and forth between evil
and crazy and yes you get it
well done and again you can totally tell
he's doing he's totally doing Adam West
Batman like imagine him fighting Adam
West and Burt Ward he would be perfectly
I mean like 100 percent you know in that
world by me with this there was nothing
there I let his origin stories like five
seconds and in this stunning courtroom
footage you know Batman tries to save
him but as he gets pointed on his face
and he blames Batman I'm like why like
you can see it right there two places
look at the note agents he got brain
damage so that's why it's like all of
this whatever excuse you throw on it's
not interesting and the original
material is just light-years it like
they're still telling stories about this
character this it's like one of the
great Batman villains if not villains in
general just so kind of like so entry
hum you can write stories about this guy
forever and there's no first cinematic
the ring with him and it's like the
racial quality to it is a little sad I
would have liked to have seen what Billy
Dee Williams did you yeah we had the
animated series and then but I mean that
doesn't really Dark Knight prove that it
doesn't really matter it's just you have
to write a good story because like Aaron
Eckhart's two-face is great yeah while
also being different but being faithful
as well it just it failed unlike
everyone not a compelling story they
switch to actors like that could have
been cooled they switch that the story
sucks I switch ads like on every other
level where the other two phases work
from Dark Knight to the animated series
to just Harvey Dent in the the Burton
film like it I'm just like wow you you
failed all of them every single yeah
yeah that's true they didn't get one
thing right the only thing that was kind
of fun just for how ridiculous it was
outside of his acting was sort the
makeup in the costume because it was
just like again it was oh so Adam let's
just let's just make it's like a perfect
lie the acid hit him just at a perfect
line down the face and the air goes
crazy and the outfits like all party and
crazy while the other is dignified and
stuff and it's like it's so over-the-top
it's kind of that was the only moment
where I'm just like yeah you kind of got
that like you got the image of him split
well done well no no but even then like
is one thing one side is hideous the
other side is you know gorgeous whatever
and like you know and dirty and destroy
I mean this one's like one size serious
kind of ugly yeah no I'm just talking
about the the way he had is like
headquarters set up yeah and with the
two henchmen and I'm like okay that's
cute but you can tell you just look at
it's like okay Adam West and without you
girl hence we would drew barrymore Louie
yes sitting there like have a mate's
dream yet yeah so it's one of those two
where it's like both this and Batman
Robin it kind of ironically ripoff the
animated series they took two of the
great idea one was Batman throwing the
other coins you know at which Woodrum I
don't think they did on the comic and
then mr. freeze within having a wife
that you know has this freeze disease or
whatever and that led to him getting
fried me also from the Amiens hero yeah
and then even just Commissioner Gordon
is now just every was a cartoon yeah I
will say this the actual cartoon
forevers defense he was already becoming
a cartoon in Batman Returns like any any
attempt to make him serious was starting
to go by the wayside but he's even more
goofy here and not as bad as batman
robin and then we even like what i think
of chase meridian I'm just like I felt
like Vicki Vale was trying to understand
Bruce Wayne I felt like there was a
personality there Selina Kyle was the
most interesting you had to kind of
characters that I thought brought a lot
of depth to their roles and she was
crazy Tim like they're really crazy they
were just this one note like honestly I
think she's the worst of the well no I
actually who was in badminton I forget
Oh nobody it was like she they have one
dinner date and that's it
I know well maybe I won't count that but
yeah I think chase Murray it's the worst
I'll say that we at least remember chase
Murray
yeah that's true oh oh boy when I think
about it now and the cold Kinmen has
done yes are these very dignified I feel
like this is an
actress that tried very hard to prove
herself as a serious actress you know
like in it she'll do somebody who
somebody did point out though and I I am
and you just know what she did this
she's like okay this is just to get my
name out there this is just to submit
myself has always kind of been like that
though to die for NOLA and like I
actually like it when she plays crazy
because she does just not give a shit
and just hmm shows she's a ton of fun
it's a show yeah she'll just throw
caution than win me like I'm just gonna
be bad shit like but even then it's like
it's a movie that has substance it's
kind of yeah or you know but I think
alike I'm saying she's always it's like
people think of having a serious career
now and everything but I'm like she
she's always been and somebody pointed
out night tend to agree that she's
always breathy again role she has this
it's very breathy it's got it for men
the coke him and it has to be you cast
the MU you cast the movie around her so
you basically have to go okay I want
this particular Nicole Kidman
performance for this film she's not
somebody that blends in know so you
wouldn't need that Nicole I need that
particular Nicole Kidman performance to
make this work and if you cast your film
right and and you're fine
but if you miss caster you're in trouble
like Paddington that was fun
you know she's out she was crazy psycho
in that and but she didn't over played
too much it was just kind of enough
reserved and she she does have this
incredible look she has kind of those
Keaton eyebrows you know just constantly
and it does give a very intense look and
I think that's she knows and she plays
that different we're all disappoints me
I'm just like man if this were written
better I feel like she could have really
done some character a psychiatrist and
not just a horny horny horny woman you
know like this would have been really
intriguing but yeah so it's I don't know
it's it's interesting it's one of those
films I actually like talking about even
though it honestly always played best
they said this is the worst movie I've
seen 40 times and it's the same thing I
just watched it over and over and over I
think everybody has that bad film like
they kind of know it's bad but it's like
I'm intrigued by you for some reason and
this was my girl say this I think three
things one I think Bruce dealing with
his dream
strangely enough works and I think it's
the most interesting thing in the movie
where I'm like there's the good movie
trying to get out
let's analyze famine and when he's got
the giant bat flying towards him and you
know I always thought that was super
have you seen the Dewey no no I know you
talked about well it's a deleted scene
and it that was a good cut there's
already enough goofy in this movie about
like at least that scene for the most
part even though it's like we've done
this before it's a little boring it
doesn't really lead to a ton of stuff
but it's like you're trying you're legit
trying you're trying out really take a
moment at Bruce Wayne just be like man
everything I'm doing this for is here I
think you know early nigma stuff I think
when Jim Carrey's not completely
overdoing it I think it works and I do
think some of the Robins stuff said just
think Chris O'Donnell's trying like and
I think like yeah I think that was I
think a lot of kids who saw it at the
time identified with it because they're
like oh a sympathetic younger character
I think the kids probably could suspend
their disbelief more than we as adults
good yeah like yeah when I was a kid
even I kind of knew it's like you know
like I love this movie in the back of my
mind I'm like you kind of know you don't
there's all these sweet things like you
don't really know what to think but I
knew like crystal everything with
crystal Dahl was solid like okay
two-phase key on the family is a little
weird but I'm like I I know that would
sound like that was a movie that was a
legit movie going on you know and
Michael golf is Alfred again I mean just
deadly hitting it out of the park the
only one to probably is skinny Batman
and Robin with any dignity
he's just so goddamn good he is just so
good and he plays all these variety of
characters and roles and he just yeah I
mean he can be a creepy monster guide he
could just be the most loving
sympathetic Cutler types
he's the most I mean we're just counting
the animated series which is advantage
to being animated he's the most
consistent Alfred I always said that I
I don't hate Michael Caine is Alfred but
what they do with their characters I'm
like he's all over the place I'm like
this one like from the beginning I I'm
like you can argue oh it's not what I
wanted from because it's different from
the comics but within the universe they
set up I'm
like yeah I see that Alfred letting
Vicky Vale in the Batcave yeah I see
that Alfred watching this continue to
unfold and go you know what I'm working
for somebody who's a little nuts I gotta
get this guy laid and I gotta get him in
a normal relationship and I gotta get
him away from this new Knights you know
what I like about the Michael Gough
Alfred honestly in every film even
Batman and Robin he is the only
connection to family that Bruce Wayne
kind yes crystal Donald comes in and
they expansive stuff but it's like I
feel free animators did that too no no I
mean if they think yeah - I mean that
that's a very good outfit but it's one
of those things where he's still mostly
talking about batarangs of the Joker's
and of course he would I mean especially
in the animated series and stuff but in
in the Burton Batman the Schumacher bama
he is always the connection back he is
always I'm gonna be here to talk about
emotional connection to friendship and
family what matters and what you know
changes and stuff like that yeah he's
always been that's anchored he's an
anchor always the argument I've made
when people like and I'm like well the
Alfred and the comics would not this
Alfred that they put in the Burton film
absolutely him not letting her into the
Batcave would be more unrealistic but
okay because it's clear the whole movie
is just setting up and really the whole
series just sets up that he's just
really uncomfortable with this where's
Michael Caine's Alfred let's do it yeah
yeah it's like no don't do it don't be
back great so just go blow no Rachael
Ray chose Kentucky Fried Chicken what
you need to do is brace your face a bet
and your do it for Gotham like it like
the and I'm here's the thing I'm okay
with that my problem with that I'll for
it is then in in Dark Knight Rises
always has a hobby to probably protect
you and I haven't fucking sent him into
this like in the past two movies and now
all of a sudden you're like because he's
going back in there do i I can't won't
use happen I'm like fuck you full
disclosure still hey rises every time I
think of it it gets worse and worse it
just oh oh don't hate it as much as you
do but I
again to the right think about the fence
between Batman Forever and Dark Knight
Rises I'm like ah man I don't know if
you'll be like well Batman Forever has
all this stupid shit it's like yeah it
does but it's it's more entertaining it
has kind of more of an understanding of
this world it doesn't yeah but there's a
lot stupid shit to me I don't know my
bears Robin it's not fucking they were
talking about that ah because Danny's
like yeah maybe yeah and Aaron's like
well I didn't he's like well it's like
just things just randomly like just know
your Patman yeah yeah it's like I saw
you and I was an orphan and I just
recognized right away that you're Batman
and Bruce Wayne's like yeah yeah I am
and it's like come on like what do you
be like yeah I know
for the for the world they were creating
and did such a good job creating in the
previous two I thought that movie just
totally they blew up their world but
yeah we're been there forever
Grint it does not have the best grasp of
this world but it has more of an
understanding I know this is a world the
glad news people talk like this it's
like everybody does that's halibut
Gothamites talk where a bad man kids say
so courage six love the car it's like
that's how we talk well you know we're
with that one it's like there's a
million the only thing I like the the
Nolan trilogy at least there is a
consistency in how it kind of looks and
feels so I'm like unlike Batman Forever
which feels completely separate from the
other yeah but I will say this it's
clear to me that Nolan like The Dark
Knight was the masterpiece he wanted to
make and then he was tapped out I and
cuz he has not done anything since when
it's come to the comment like Man of
Steel that and anything really is
remotely as interesting as they feel
like that was the one and then they're
like we'll do another way he's like yeah
honestly I'll just be again this goes
back because a man begins on retread we
bring back like yeah half the plot
points from that well and I'll be honest
I mean kind of like what I was saying
with Schumacher I'm sure Chris rondall
is a super nice guy I would not want to
be him for the world I can't I can't
even begin to grasp the stress that do
must be under I mean not yet I mean
think about people that died
on your shoots and people you know like
what Dark Knight Rises begin there was a
shooting and stuff like that I mean just
imagining that on you I mean I can't
imagine so anytime I talk about this I'm
talking about them as my things I'm not
like oh it's like I
I can't imagine when they don't work
we're at a point where it's like if
people can't figure that out yeah yeah I
always want for fun you know I just it's
clear to me that that that was the one
that he wanted to make that and he
wanted to try and top it yeah and and
it's good I think it's bad he just was
kind of like tap out it to the point
that it's like yeah like really he kind
of was like producing Man of Steel but
like he's just moved away for like he's
dunkirk I thought that was an amazing
movie like he's done other things since
then for better or worse depending on
whether you like him or not like I feel
like that I just feel like that was just
that was his idea was like Dark Knight
and he's like and I'm down in this
universe like after Dark Knight happened
and he was such an explosion I mean like
suddenly comic book movies I'm like
they're not just coming up they're like
they're how did this not get an Oscar
nominee even though like you know which
for the Marvel DC battle I always you
know I know DC takes it's it's but I'm
just like I always go the dark nights
like the 85 Bears it's just like now it
seems like so long ago but it was so
good
they were so live in history but I feel
like you know like again like if I was
in his shoes like suddenly like you've
made what God people call it the
greatest comic book movie for me it's
like Olivia but I tried doing this
inception idea I've always wanted to try
you know let me try this and that was a
big kid everybody loved it well blew my
mind and he's like you know what felt
like just like Dark Knight Rises and oh
was that awful spacewalk interstellar
interstellar and stuff you know he's
just like I I can do that and to its
credit it's like one of those guys where
it's like yeah maybe he could uh but
they just got too wordy and they got too
aware of their importance which is why I
like it when dunker came around he's
just like said you know what I got a
people are kind of saying I'm over time
let me just go total opposite like yeah
that would actually could have used a
little more
yeah and very different it's not
something where I feel like everybody
would be like yeah I like that though
it's a different kind of and I always
feel like he's experimenting and it's
like I don't have to like all of his
movies like but it just feels like after
dark night it was just like that was it
when it came to Batman and the you know
it's just like I feel like there was a
pride feel like yeah I feel like Dark
Knight Rises like he just just was
something not clicking there and a Man
of Steel like I don't I somehow feel
like I don't know what his involvement
is he's got executive producer credit
and like a silver but yeah what's me
also story yeah and I'm like I could see
some of it but I just I don't know it
feels like there's a disconnect cuz I'm
like yeah I don't know he never came
back
yeah I feel like he's just he's done
with that um yeah I feel like they were
like well Dark Knight was super huge we
want you to kind of put your and just
have your fingerprints on here because
you know just had cuz they made a lot of
money and a lot of people liked him so
he wanted no one named a time here and
again I feel like he was like I'll do
what I know I could see story elements
Amana steel but I mean so much of the
shittiness of that movie is David Goyer
yeah definitely yeah but what not wasn't
that was he managed to ortho esters
Batman vs Superman no he was I'm pretty
sure he was a tailor but um but you can
definitely sense the nolan touches in
there too but yet that is not Nolan's
film you know yeah but anyway how this
all ties back to Batman Forever is that
yes it's one of those things where it's
like even though I can see people like
you and I can see people I can more
easily see people hating it like I said
this was released now it be despised but
I feel like the people that like it I I
get it it is the lighter cartoon Batman
like say even more than the cartoon was
the cartoon Batman and I can't compare
it to something like a well such a
Batman brave in the bold like I couldn't
get into it it's like these really old
Batman stories where they're kind of
hokey but they're trying to be serious
too and I I couldn't dig it but I know a
lot of people that do and I feel
this is kind of like been a forever is
that just with less substance like it is
on its own it's like that they do what
kind of a goofy comic-book e a little
bit of the 60s but with a little bit of
substance I feel like kind of Batman
Forever is that though it doesn't really
go all the way with either one so it
also can't offend as hard if that makes
sense where Batman Robin just went you
know over the top can watch it and feel
like adults and adults can sit through
it and not claw their eyes out yeah
that's Batman Forever and I'm not sure
yeah whereas Batman and Robin nobody
wins but there's a lot of kids that
people I grew up with that movie saying
they liked it but all of them were like
I was a kid I have not been one adult
that was like I saw it came out and it
loved it I like I'm sure you're out
there I just haven't met you yet it's
usually kids they grow up it's like
stupid things as like Oh bright colorful
and Batman you know like you're going to
give what a little kid babies like
Teletubbies that doesn't mean that you
know there's ro Batman I mean that is
exactly what Batman or Robin would be I
mean they talk like little kids and it's
a bright colorful like what little kids
are like so I
swardson hanger there's the only thing
in that goddamn here boy what can be
done sauce di snatch so when I just when
we did because I don't think we'll ever
do this but when we did the writing for
a bama forever like I think you should I
get about three to four pages of notes
on a movie and this one I had eight and
like I just I had these sketch ideas in
mind as like I just had to cut pretty
much all of them except a little bit in
the beginning cuz I'm just like I I
can't there's just too many jokes to
make I had to cut so many others out of
it so there's one I really wanted to
talk about we oh I think we always get
choked about this might even been
Brian's idea I'm not sure but we always
said to face the talk show and it's just
Tommy Lee Jones to face and like all he
does everyone that comes out he's always
like have you seen a ball bat and like
that's all you ever talked about is like
uh no no I have not ha ha well tell us
about this move
um coming out that doesn't have the bat
like that's just everything and then
like every time like the person's trying
to talk he's just turning to the camera
I'm trying to talk about this movie yeah
quiet I don't want to hear about your
movie yet huh still though okay I wanna
hear about your movie now like we just
had this whole bid that I don't think
we'll ever see the light of day I don't
I can't think of any point where we can
really feel like everything watching
somebody have a meltdown
well you do that I'm just like well so
that's what he's gonna look like when
he's 90 in his dementia 60 but yeah so
that that's my sketch I don't think will
ever happen but and it could be like the
Dana Carvey show where only I think it's
funny like only the person that wrote it
funny but it's like I just think it's so
funny because nobody's gonna do anything
with that two-face ever and he's such a
laugh he is so much fun yeah you know
what that's that's the difference BAM in
forever he's the Schwarzenegger of the
movie but there's other things around
the movie that I feel are redeemable or
at least make it still interesting to
watch whereas Bama and Robin and Mike
it's just short sitting here there's
nothing else yeah because there's
nothing outside from the again the
visuals are kind of yeah I mean too much
color to it it just was visual overload
but yeah you're right whereas Wharton it
felt a little bit more like I can latch
onto you because you're a little fun you
know you're just so crazy you know I'll
tell you where with Tommy Lee Jones it's
like well there's a good might be almost
here it's an you and I were a little
left in the room and you just got to
watch all the carnage he created yeah
my favorite description of him I you
hold mr. cranky reviews the movies
website but the I think he had some line
about Schwarzenegger sounds like to
Austrians belching into a job with the
big smile making the worst jokes that he
just thinks are amazing like did you
hear these eyes fun oh my god
max I used to see you yeah I picked this
part she is just this kind of fake his
same thing with a great show yeah he is
having so much my gift to you
guys enjoy it as I'm enjoying your
welcome there is something strangely
adorable about him and there's so many
reasons I said but there's so reasons to
make their neck kind of way yeah cuz if
you don't love him he might kill you
oddly just make a terrible I spun which
is kind of he's just like an overgrown
muscle-bound
he's like if I may respects he's kind of
genius for these kind of a moron - it's
like that weird balance of like I kind
of I love you and hate you at the same
time you're kind of amazing you're this
beautiful paradox but it's all extreme
there's something about certain extremes
that just like Batman Forever stupid
guess what I do that did you
so that's you've talked about everything
you can about Batman yeah I think I'm
good I fantasize judean I did I
exercised the Schumacher out of me I
guess so I don't know riddle me this
what kind of man has bits on the brain
Wonder Woman
now let's know trying to figure out
which joke which appears like all the
different superheroes it's like Aquaman
Wonder Woman spider-man like God so yeah
there it is
that's our thoughts and those let me
know below what if do you guys still do
you still really like BAM ever
hater what like where does it rank now
I'm curious now like where it ranks
third for me out of the original four I
mean yeah by me just a like ever hated
as I never I didn't hate it then I don't
hate it now it's just yeah so I'm
curious I'm curious grown to hate this
move they still like can I have you know
kind of thing but you got something
nothing as a man she's can I so what if
season one no character so I was looking
for baby wait a minute I pay you money
to have you make me feel good and it
looks like you're gonna touch me all
over there's another name for that
who are your influences Freud Freud and
Freud so guys that's about it we will
see it the next row thought so we talk
about bats are not rodents doctor I
don't know that you are interesting well
my knowledge of rodents is immense
you